didier laguerre bonjour bonjour maire de
fort de france et également conseiller
communautaire à la casse m alors on va
commencer par ce qui s'est produit cette
semaine la cathédrale saint louis 1 qui
a été la cible de vandalisme une série
d'ailleurs de d'actes de vandalisme
alors vous avez réagi dans dans les
heures qui ont suivi 1
vous avez bien sûr condamné avec la plus
grande fermeté ces agissements
vous assurez votre soutien au père
catayée et puis et puis vous avez
annoncé avoir pris la décision de
renforcer la surveillance de l'édifice
en y affectant un agent de sécurité la
police municipale elle peut pas servir
aussi à protéger ce type de lieu didier
laguerre c'est une question oui c'est
une question de nouveau tetris auditeurs
de l'entée ni première j'ai tendance à
dire il faut oui et la cathédrale a été
vandalisée il ya eu plusieurs intrusions
dans la cathédrale
d'abord par le chantier de réflexion et
par exemple on a intrusions et sa cage
ou une intrusion sa cage
ils sont entrés en cassant des vitres
qui viennent d'être refaits sur le
chantier donc on a commencé par votre
enfance et la sécurité sur le chantier
et on a constaté qu'ils sont ensuite
rentrés en jeu dit il je sais pas si
c'est le pluriel
en tout cas que ce que celui ou ceux qui
sont entrés dans la cathédrale sont
entrés par l'arrière c'est par là par la
petite coquille derrière par la
sacristie ont escaladé un mur il encore
cassé une vitre pour pouvoir pénétrer
dans l'antre dans la sacristie
dès les premières intrusions nous avons
demandé une enquête de gendarmerie de
police nous allons porter plainte
j'ai aussi demandé aux responsables du
chantier de renforcer la sécurité au
niveau du chantier les faits et on
continue et s'étend de déplacés nous
avons donc pris la décision de mettre
vigilant l'intérieur de la cathédrale le
soin il ya des rondes de police qui sont
organisées
il ya une enquête qui est en cours avec
les caméras de vidéoprotection qui nous
ferait vraiment là d'identifier le ou
les auteurs de ces faits de façon à
faire cesser mais je suis vraiment
révolté par le fait qu' on puisse pin
écrit comme ça dans un lieu de culte
dans un lieu symbolique des martiniquais
qui réunit beaucoup de martinique un
lieu symbolique pour pour saccager pour
vandaliser c'est vraiment un signe aussi
qu'il ya une des livres de notre société
dans notre société alors ça ne dit pas
aussi quelque chose de la vie nocturne
du du centre-ville foyalais je parlais
de la police municipale bon bien sûr il
ya la police nationale aussi bons qu'ils
peuvent faire des rondes etc
mais c'est vrai que bon vous ne pouvez
pas non plus la nuit de police qui sont
postés et qui circulent en haut valais
ce que je le sentiment d'insécurité kiki
oui mais a filmé le sauteur il faut y
aller ou ceux qui passent la nuit
quelque chose de particulièrement de
particulièrement subjectif
lorsque vous prenez les éléments les
chiffres je rappelle que nous avons un
conseil local de prévention de la
sécurité et la délinquance nous
travaillons en étroite collaboration
avec les services de l'état la police
municipale nous avons beaucoup de
services de qui courait sur la
prévention et sur sur les paul mattick
de délinquance quand vous prenez
l'évolution des chiffres sur les deux
trois dernières années vous avez de
nette diminution dans un certain nombre
de domaines
des chiffres en matière de vol de vol à
l'arraché de d'imposition etc
maintenant vous à nous avons aussi à
travailler sur le sur l'environnement
c'est ce que nous continuons à
l'ambiance mais
je suis je suis vraiment je suis
vraiment désolé vous mettrez toutes les
mesures de sécurité en place
c'est quand même c'est quand même assez
particulier
dalé vandalisé saccagé un édifice commun
comme une cathédrale qui en cours de
rénovation de vandalisme se sont quand
même plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'euros qui sont engagés sur les lits
travaux de réhabilitation de la
cathédrale qui retrouve son aspect
originel il ya c'est quand même quand
même particulier oui il faut
probablement renforcer là même qui
prétendent magico religieux peut-être à
mai mentionné que quand même il faut
aussi qu'on se penche sur une
problématique de ce site et et sur les
problématiques d'éducation parce que il
faut bien sûr traiter le mal c'est comme
quand vous êtes malade 1 il faut quitter
les symptômes il faut soigner mais il
faut aussi travailler dans la prévention
dont celle et polluera type d'éducation
il faut renforcer nos dispositifs en
matière d'éducation en matière
d'accompagnement des familles le matière
d'accompagnement des jeunes il faut
aussi renforcer la capacité que nous
donnons aux martiniquais de pouvoir
s'épanouir et de pouvoir se projeter
dans l'avenir
alors le maire de fort de france at il
perçu ces foyal qui font un peu triste
mine alors cet incident a évidemment
enfin grave incident n'a pas contribué à
remonter le un peu un peu le moral parce
que les foyalais font un peu triste mine
comme le coeur de ville quoi de fort de
france didier laguerre qui n'affiche pas
particulièrement cette année de décor de
fête de fin et début d'année et vous me
direz c'est un peu partout presque
pareil mémé foyal foyal sexuelle la plus
grosse ville joie je vous dise parce je
vous dis les premièrement c'est un peu
partout pareil
deuxièmement oui c'était déjà le cas
l'année dernière c'était déjà le cas les
années précédentes
la ville a investi jusqu'à deux cent
mille euros pour réaliser des
éliminations
il faut bien se rendre compte que ce
soit des coûts qui sont quand même
importante si faim cette année non non
non dans le passé jusqu'à deux cent
mille euros pour réaliser pour louer
parce que ce qui s' il faut voir ce que
c'est ces lots est d'aider des
guirlandes des motifs et c6 mobiliser
les services de l'éclairage public
je ne parviens pas d'argent pour ça se
focaliser les services de l'éclairage
public et qui laissent leur activité de
réparation des des lampadaires pour
pouvoir poser a été posée cesser ces
guirlandes
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas les moyens
d'investir pour pouvoir procéder à ces
décorations il faut faire des choix
gérer c'est aussi faire des choix c'est
5 millions d'euros de recettes en moins
sur le budget de 2016 et 2017 c'était
déjà le cas de 2014 à 2015
c'était déjà le cas l'année précédente
quand vous avez une contraction de vos
recettes comme ça vous êtes amené à vous
expliquer ça aussi aux commerçants parce
que oui nous nous sommes là nous l'avons
eu aux commerçants à l'association des
commerçants depuis depuis des années
déjà
eux ils ont les seins je veux bien qu'on
en discute et centres commerciaux
fonctionne de façon totalement
différente
je rappelle que les centres commerciaux
sont des groupements d'intérêt
économique et que ce sont les
commerçants eux mêmes qui financent les
les décorations qui finance les
animations qui finance les promotions
qui sont organisées dans le centre
commercial c'est parce que les
commerçants du centre adopté un peu ce
type 2 nous avons travaillé nous avons
travaillé avec l'organisation des
commerçants de façon ajustements et nous
continuons à travailler avec eux nous
avons mis en place le conseil foyalaise
sur le centre ville pour travailler avec
les commerçants mais les acteurs de les
associations les citoyens vous
travaillez à la dynamique d'animation de
la ville nous avons des projets avec
l'association des commerçants
il faut que chacun intervient que chacun
prenne une part de la change ya pas si
longtemps que ça il ya des commerces et
des enseignes qui ont posé des
décorations et qui ont participé à cette
animation pas tout attendre non plus de
lance de la ville et de la décence
publique et de la puissance publique ce
sont des fonds qui sont prélevés d'une
façon ou d'une autre sur les impôts des
uns et des autres
de même les commerçants peuvent aussi
décoré leurs vitrines
tout ça tout ça concourt à la dynamique
d'animation de la ville et il faut qu'on
continue à travailler avec nous
néanmoins on a noté que le stationnement
est gratuit 1 depuis le 15 oui ça fait
de nombreuses années que je sors au 31
décembre de façon à faciliter si pour
peu que tout le monde joue le jeu
parce que le stationnement gratuit ça
veut dire que notre objectif est de
permettre aux clients de trouver plus
facilement des places de stationnement
mais ça veut dire aussi qu'il ne faut
pas que ceux qui travaillent à fort de
france viennent yp stationner leur
véhicule à 6 heures du matin au moment
je suis en train de parler et que il
pente à 17 heures parce qu'à ce moment
là ça veut dire que le client ne
trouvera pas de place donc il faut là
encore que chacun s'implique et que
chacun joue le jeu alors et puis les
bouts comme d'hab est aussi auront bien
lieu donc le 30 le 30 décembre les deux
chronos descendent lieu avec les une
programmation artistique yves à vouziers
l'ordre empêchent j'aimerais bien connu
mais bon pour ceux qui viendraient
d'arriver en martinique
c'est donc les feux d'artifice qui sont
tirés dans la baie des flamands la baie
de fort de france
ça attire bien sûr des fouilles à l'est
mais ça veut dire quoi que j'en aie aie
aie pas que c'est l'autre côté de la
baie vous avez par exemple l'huile et
les commerces de base il est content du
coup c'était parce que à la dernière
séance plénière de l'assemblée de la
collectivité territoriale
il ya une petite passe d'armes verbale
entre donc que johnny jarre qui on le
rappelle est l'un de vos adjoints
au maire de fort de france et
marie-hélène léotin qui est la
conseillère exécutive en charge des
affaires de la culture du patrimoine etc
et puis johnny jarre a dit oui bah on a
reçu un courrier comme quoi la ctn ne va
plus contribué ne va plus subventionner
partiellement ses bouquins de la baie
marie hélène et hautain s'est inscrite
en faux johnny jarre est revenu à la
charge il insiste elle a dit bon je peux
fournir le courrier que la mairie a reçu
comme quoi la ctm annonce son intention
de ne plus financer en partie nous avons
nous mêmes nous avons reçu de nombreux
courriers des le dès le début de l'année
2016 dès le tout début de l'année 2016
j'ai reçu des courriers annonçant la non
participation de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique on parle de
la baie mais moi je parle de 10
festivals aussi rejetant les festivals
de la ville de fort de france sur
laquelle nous avons reçu dix ans il
n'est pas éligible aux fonds européens
alors que nous avons toujours été
financé à hauteur de 3,5 4,5 millions
par les fonds européens
donc vous confirmez ce que je nie à jaar
a déclaré je vis je complète me confirme
avoir reçu un courrier indiquant que le
festival culturel de la ville de fort de
france n'est pas éligible aux fonds
européens
je confirme avoir reçu un courrier
gibloux fonds européens européens qu'ils
ont géré par la société nettoyage
martinique et anciennement par le
conseil régional
je confirme avoir reçu un courrier
indiquant que le carnaval de fort de
france
le carnaval organisateurs ont dû
finalement peut-être je ne sais pas vous
allez demander des explications sur
divers vous savez moi je discute à
partir des écrits un courrier indiquant
que le carnaval n'était pas éligible aux
fonds européens et l'alliance est pris
en compte dans le budget 2010 est de
façon à pouvoir assumer en ne comptant
pas sous ses ressources à tout en
pouvant déplorable que ce soit la région
martinique la cité m qui a dit que le
carnaval et le festival ne sont pas
finançable par les fonds européens
merci aux comptes donne affaire à suivre
merci didier laguerre d'avoir répondu à
nos questions ce matin joyeux noël merci
joyeux noël à tous les mappings caser
tous les martiniquais qui nous écoutent